With the Sochi Winter Olympic games just around
the corner, athletes will be competing for
bronze, silver and gold...or will they? The
winners will actually receive a gold medal
made almost entirely of sterling silver. This
first place medal will be practically identical
to the silver medal, except it must be covered
in at least 6 grams of pure gold. In fact,
it was in the year 1912 that the last solid
gold medal was handed out. The current bronze
medal is made of a metal alloy composed of
mostly copper and tin - potentially valued
at only $4. Meanwhile, athletes who win first
place on February, 15th, 2014, will receive
"cosmic medals" which are gold medals embedded
with fragments of the super bolide meteor
which exploded over Chelyabinsk Russia exactly
one year ago.
But gold medals weren't always awarded to
champions. At the Games of the I Olympiad
in 1896, winners received a silver medal along
with an olive branch. The runner up got a
bronze medal with third place finishers receiving
nothing. China also received nothing at the
olympics for a long period of time, with their
first olympic medal coming in 1984.
And while the Olympians may train in gynasiums,
the word gymnasium actually comes from the
greek word "gymnos" meaning naked. So it's
no surprise that ancient greeks competing
in the olympics were completely nude. Nudity
would be hard to pull off at the winter olympics
though, which occurred for the first time
in 1924 in (SHAMONEY) Chamonix, France.
Shortly after this date, in 1936, The Olympics
were broadcast on television for the first
time. Held in Berlin Germany, during the Nazi
regime, the fuzzy black and white images replaced
conventional radio coverage, drawing an estimated
audience of 150,000 viewers.
Though as the Olympics grows older, some olympians
seem to be getting younger; the youngest ever
olympic medal winner was Dimitrios Loundras,
who was awarded a bronze medal in gymnastics
at the age of 10. On the other hand the oldest
olympic medal winner was Oscar Swahn, who
won an olympic silver medal in shooting at
the age of 72.
The first snowboarding olympic event was held
in Nagano in 1998. It was Canadian Ross Rebagliati
who infamously took home the first gold medal
ever in this event. In a scandal, he lost
his medal the next day because nanograms of
marijuana were found in his body. Claiming
the cause was second hand smoke at the time,
Ross is now entering the medical marijuana
business with his first cannabis cafe opening
in Whistler entitled Ross' Gold.
Mix that gold with the blue, red, green, and
black rings - and white background - and you
get the Olympic logo, representing the colours
of every countries flag in the world. Unlike
the two cancelled Winter Olympics during World
War II, it's a reminder of our international
communities consistently coming together.
And because of all the excitement surrounding
the Olympics, we've decided to release a video
every single day, starting this Thursday,
February 6th for 19 days straight. Can't wait?
Our amazing partners at the CBC already have
5 of the videos up now, for you to binge on!
Just head to cbc.ca/olympics/sciencesays to
watch them before anyone else - there's a
clickable link in the description below!
That's right, we'll be looking at your burning
questions like why we get nervous, does sex
affect athletic performance, the ideal Olympic
diet, and more. It's a science blitz!
But we also want to know YOUR questions for
this special series! Use the hashtag #ScienceSays
and let us know your burning Olympic questions!
And as always - subscribe for more awesome science
videos!